he's led germany's most populous state
for nearly four years
soon army lashit will be leading his
national party
with a clear direction in mind the cdu
and the csu
are the last remaining parties which can
guarantee social cohesion which is under
threat right now
we see it out on the streets with the
coronavirus lots of aggression
people who deny the virus exists and
others who are lying in the charity
hospital
500 meters away who are fighting for
their lives
and we feel this polarization of society
and many other areas too
and the cdu has always been about
bringing different positions together
although saturday's vote needs to be
confirmed by the entire party membership
for many armin lashed is a continuity
candidate
his slogan was that i'm the
representative of the executive branch
so if you vote for me you can be sure
you get a leader
you get someone actually who had one
election so none of the other two
candidates actually ever
won an election governing in his state
during the pandemic has been an ordeal
for lashed
the numbers of infections and deaths
there have been among the highest in
germany
and back when the incidence of covid was
much lower he argued for less stringent
lockdowns hoping to protect the economy
as much as the people now his message
has changed
as he eyes the general election it's
important to point out that winning the
party leadership on its own does not
bring with it the right to work here
the german chancellery angela merkel has
already said she intends to serve out
her term here
so in order to replace her the new party
leader must win september's general
election
but before he can do that he may have to
deal with another leading conservative
marcus zurder head of the cdu sister
party in bavaria the christian social
union
he could be the center-right candidate
in the autumn
many conservatives say they would rather
vote for him as chancellor than any
other candidate
so far zerda has played down the
suggestion
but not ruled it out completely meaning
amin lashed has much to do if he wants
to replace angelimerco
in the autumn dominic kane al jazeera
berlin